よろしくお願いします
今日の話のテーマは 何のために生きているのかというわからなくなったらということで
ブッダの説く生きる目的
生きがいというのは何でしょうかと
生きる目的っていうのは
だいたいこの若い人々の気持ちというのは考えて
いろいろテーマを作りますけど
ちょっと計算違いかもしれません
この仏教で言っていることは
理解するためには まあやっぱり物事を判断する能力っていうのは必要なんですよ
ある人に言われたことなんですけど
この自分がこの自分の友達に
あの こういういろいろ本とかね
あの貸してあげたんだと
で その友達が言うのは
まあ言ってることはわかるんだけど
自分が奥さんと喧嘩すると
それはどうやって解決できるかと
それは一番大事な問題で
それはわからないんだと
こういうものを読んでも
瞬間に頭に浮かんだのは
もう一度人間に生まれ変わった方がどうですかと
単純な理屈をわからないんだったら
もう生きることはできないんじゃないか
その瞬間に思ったんです
なぜならば 私は一貫して言ってるのはそういうことなんです
お祈りしたっても 南無妙法蓮華経と言ったっても
あれやこれやとか まあ祈祷やら何やっても
そんな宗教臭いなことやっても人間の役に立ちませんと
今喧嘩しているあなたはどうやって喧嘩をやめますか？と
今怒っているあなたはどうやって怒りを収めますかと
そういう具体的なことをずっと何 10年も喋っているのに
それは言ってないんだというならば
どう言えばいいかと自分ではわからなくなっちゃうんですね
よっぽど精神的な病気じゃないかなと思います
ですから このちょっとこの知識レベルが足らないということはもう申し訳ないんですけど
すごく痛感しているんです
で あの 別にこの学校の教育とかね
哲学とかそういうものを置いておいて
ごく普通な単純な人間持ってる理性っていうのはね
それはもうちょっと蘇ってみた方がどうかなと思います
そんな大した哲学者になる必要もないし
あの もういろいろ無意味なデータを頭にもう溜まっておいて
訳もわからない状態に
そういうことではなくて
まあただ単純に あの 我々は道路を歩くときは
車が来るんだったらちょっと避けちゃうし
料理していて 何かつい鍋を触ったらすぐ熱くて火傷するそうになっちゃう
その瞬時に手を引っ張っちゃって
あのもうもう なんでか耳蓋っていうんですか
これ触ったりするし まあそんなもんの常識な理屈は必要ですよ
なんでそれはないかとわからないんです
だから お腹が空いた私はどうすればいいかというふうなことではね
それで私はではご飯食べなさいと
どうやってご飯食べますか？と聞くと
それで はい ご飯持ってきますから
これはご飯ですよと これはどうやって食べますか？と
それはお箸で食べますよと
箸って何ですか？と 箸はこれですよと
どこまで言うんですかね
それであの じゃあ箸でこうやって取るんだよと
それで取ってどうするんですか？と聞くと
取って口に入れるんだよと
で 口に入れてどうするんですか？と
で 噛むんだよと 噛んでからどうする？飲み込むんだよと
飲み込んだらどうなるんですか？と
それでまあ そのまま続けてくださいって言うでしょうね
そうすると それやったって
私はお腹が空いてるんだけど
また逆に言うんだったら
どう言えばいいんですかね
だからほとんどの人々っていうのは
なんか分からないんですけど
まあそんなタイプなんですね
それで それを続けた人が
あの まあどうせ当然あのお腹空いてる状態なくなるでしょうね
それはなくなっても 前はお腹が空いてて
今はお腹が空いてないんですけど
あなたの教えは全然役に立ちませんでしたって言うでしょうに
だから あの そういうふうな生き方で
特に先進国々は生きているんですよ
だからこの先進国々だというと
高慢を捨てた方がいいんです
もう今はもう私にも時間ないんだから
言いたいことは素直にと直接言うんです
遠慮する必要ないし 私もそろそろ年でしょうし
ですから このずーっとなんかこの知識傲慢で
先進国傲慢で 人のことをバカにするんですね
もう最低のアホがヨーロッパから来て何か言うと
ものすごい それはもうそのまま信じるだけの生き方で
だから明らかにそれ間違ってるとわかってももう理解しない
驚いたのは あさひ教団にはいまだに超能力
超能力ある宗教者やとインディの連中が思ってるんだから
もう呆れちゃうんですよ
この人間のこの頭の良ささというかね
まあそういうことですから
このまあ一応こういう目的っていうのは
いくらか元気で これから明るく生きてみようという人々を目指して喋っていることなんです
自分で人生を諦めているんだったら
この話も役に立たないとは思います
だから負けず嫌い 失敗はしたくない
どうせやるなら成功してやるぞという
そういうタイプの人々に
泣いたりわめたり生きたくはないんだよと
そういういくらかこの
そういう風な精神を持っている
いくらか希望ある人々ということを想定して
あのを喋ります で あまりあのスライドを作ろうと紙芝居を作ろうと思ったんですけど
なかなか紙芝居的にはならないんですね
これはあまりにも生きることに関係あるものだから
すべてファジーで曖昧なんです
だからこのモットーみたいに
この何て言いますか 何言というんですか
あの一言葉で 一話題でこれを覚えておきましょう
これはいい言葉だなとかね
そういうふうなものっていうのは
もうなかなか出てこない
出てくるんだったら 私はもう大体 30 分もあればまあ作れますけど
作らなかった だからこのスクリーン出したのは
もし黒板の代わりに黒板使いたくなったら使ってみようかなということで
だからスクリーンはあまり気にしないでください
ただ迷惑だけかもしれません
それで このテーマに対して皆様にこの報告なさったこと言葉が説明文章があります
で 今日はこの説明文章に沿っていきます
今までは説明文章終わったところから進んでましたけど
人生は苦しみの連続です
次から次へと苦難の苦難は訪れ
こんなことばかりならば死んでしまいたいと思うことさえもあるかもしれません
しかし そんな時でも 自分の生きる目的
生きがい 希望を見出すことのできる人は
耐えがたいほどの苦しみに出会っても生き抜くことができるでしょう
というところ で それでこちらに書いてましたけど
人生は苦難の連続ですと
それで皆様方はそれは本当かないかと
生きるということは苦難の連続ですか？と
まずそちらにチャレンジしてみてほしいんです
嘘じゃないかと そういうふうな態度でチャレンジしてみるんです
生きることに こんな苦難の連続と言ったっても
誰が言っただけで信じるもんかと
ああ そうですかと言ったら
もう頭が悪いんです ではなくて
本当に生きるということは苦難の連続ですか？と
調べてみますと チャレンジしてみますという風に
まず自分で発見するということが必要なんですよ
この自分で発見するということは絶対人間しないんだからこそ
もうどうにもならないんですね
ただ動いている肉の塊だけなんです
もう将来的に医学が発展すると
そうやって肉だけ生かしていく方法もあるんだから
今もありますよ このいろいろ臓器の一部一部とかね
もう生かしておくんです
提供者が死んでも もうかなり時間経ってますけど
何年も 臓器いろいろ移植する部分とかはまあずっと生かしておく
それで病気患者が出たらすぐそれを移植しちゃうと
だから医学的にもできるんだからね
我々もそんな感じで ただ細胞が生きているだけといえばね
あまり面白くないんです
そういうことだから いつでもまず必要なことが自分で発見する
何を言われても 何を言われても鵜呑みにしないで
あ そうですか 本当ですかね
で 若者でもマジっすか？と聞くんだけど
それで終わっちゃうんです
あれ マジ昔は真面目ですかというね
ことで それはあまりにも省略して省略
今マジっすかになってますけどね
まあそれは別にいいんですけど
ただマジっすかだけで終わって欲しくないんですよ
物事は それ 反応自体も無関心な反応なんです
まあ本当はマジ それで終わっちゃうんです
だから この無関心な反応で自分が立ち触れないようにしているぞという気持ちなんですけど
本当はものすごく精神的に弱くて
何でも鵜呑みにする 自分で何も一つも判断できない人格がそのまま続くだけ
だからただ細胞が生きているだけ
これでは人生というのはちょっと言いづらいんですね
だから最初からもうこちらでももう固定して前提として書いちゃったんです
人生は苦難の連続ですと
では本当ですかと そこら辺は調べてみてほしいんです
もし客観的に調べてみると
一概に苦難の連続とは言えないはずなんです
でも誰一人もチャレンジしたことがないんです
私に まあそうですねというだけで
よくよく見ると全然分かってないんです
だって何年経っても成長
成功って見えませんだから
時々みんな仲良く喋ってる時
その声の波動が伝わるんですよ
いや だがもう全くのこの知恵の世界じゃないかなと
まるっきりデス世界ではないかとと感じちゃうんですね
だから いくらふざけてごちゃごちゃ喋って遊び遊んでいても
あの知恵に基づいているか
ただのアホかということをすごく波動でわかるんです
ただ感情で犬猫を鳴くような感じでキャーキャーキャーキャーと鳴いているか
もうわざとふざけているかということは 2つなんです
ただ感情で喋っていることと
もうわざと面白おかしくしてふざけて
もういろんなうるさいことを言っていると
それはものすごい違うんです
波動が わざとふざけて遊んだりすると
その波動っていうのは結構気分がいいんです
ただ感情でキャーキャーキャーキャーと鳴いちゃうと
もうもうもう小鼓まで響くんですよ
そういうことで この生きるということは
このあまり苦難の連続と言っても
我々知っている苦難の連続で
我々の立場で見てみると
やっぱり苦もあって楽もあるということになるかもしれません
人生っていうのは そこで私はずっと言っているのは
そこら辺で冷静になって判断してはいけない
ブッダ楽だとかね やっぱり客観的に分析してみる
あ ここら辺は楽 ここら辺は嫌
ここら辺はもうなんています
面白くないとか 自分の人生の中でいろんな経験があります
全く最悪の経験もありますね
すごい楽しい経験もあります
すごく面白くない経験もあります
それでつまらないものもあります
つまらないと言ったっても
つまらなくてたまらない時もあります
それでいろんなものがあります
大変だなと思う時もあります
しかし もう大変どうしようもない時もありますよ
だから大変だなということにもいろんなランクがありますよ
あ 大変だと言ったっても
いろいろ意味があるんです
例えば究極には大変だ
どうしようもない お手上げだ
何もやることできないということもあります
これは大変だよと言いながらやれるものもあります
また 大変だと言っても
まあ頑張ればなんとかなるんじゃないかなという大変さもあります
あ これ頑張っても無理だという大変さもあります
頑張らなくてはいかないんだけど
これはどうにもならないんだよと
本当に大変だよということもあります
ですから 大変だと言ってもいろんな大変があります
人生は苦しいんだと言ったっても
あらゆる苦しみがあります
だからこれはこの何万色の色のような感じで
あの色の配列はなんて言いますか
この 今日はあの人来てないね
グラデーションですか
グラデーションでもう 1つ言葉あります
科学的な言葉  色調ですか？色彩とか
だから日本語で英語の英語の単語忘れちゃったんだけど
まあいいです とにかく青いと言ったっても
あらゆる青いがあります
赤いと言ったっても あらゆる赤があります
黄色いと言ったっても
たくさん黄色いがあります
そこで横に縦に配列があるんですよ
スペクトラム だからスペクトラムということ
だからスペクトラムというのは横にも縦にもあります
横というのは この青いがあって
緑があって 黄色いがあって
赤があって 白いがあって
いろいろ それは横のスペクトラムで
縦っていうのは青いの中でもたくさんの青いがあって
黄色いの中でも限りなく黄色いがあってとかね
そこが人生なんです 明るく元気で頑張って生きていきたいと思うならば
ただ いい加減で この英語でいう単語があります
このスイーピングステートメントという
これはちょっとまあ批判的な言葉なんですけど
どこでしたっけ？これのあれが
すごい方はわからないな
それだったら当たり前ですね
はい ちょっと開けましょうか
新しい講義 ですね じゃあ機械が立ち上がるまで
えーと この我々はこのスイーピングステーク
スイーピングというのは
まあもうなんて言いますか
ほうきでやること なんて言いますか
掃除ですか 掃除するような感じ
全部まとめてっぽいと一つでまとめようとするんですね
あのゴミを分別しないで捨てるような感じで
だから人生について みんななんでそんなことをするんですかと
これやめてほしい 例えば不正が悪人やとかね
いい加減にしなさいと
完璧な悪人は存在するわけじゃないんです
で あの 例えば日本で あの
あの金正日という人が
もうもうものすごい大バカもんというか
ね 嫌な人でイメージ描いてますけど
この間 ソ連のなんかおじいさんをインタビューしてあったんですね
あの元軍事の司令官か何とかやった人が
その人はものすごく褒めるんですね
まあ自分はよく個人的には知っていて
大変謙虚な人だと すっごく勉強するんだと
頭がすごくいいんだと
で いろんなことを言うんですね
ものすごく謙虚な人だと
あれ いつでもああいうかっこ悪い不細工なあの服しか着ないんだと
で 言ってみれば考えちゃうと
あ なるほどなと思いますよ
だからこの神様として仕立てられているんですけど
なかなかその人はそんなに外へ出ようとはしないし
まあ一応スイーピングステートメントという言葉だけ書いて
まあ英語を書いたってもあまり面白くないかもしれませんですけど
これにはもしかすると日本語もありますかね
ちょっと人から見ると
いわゆる包括ですかね
一方的にはいいけど  じゃないんですね
一掃する  えっ  一掃する
全部  一掃する  包括的ですか
包括的  全面的とか全否定とかっていうんですかね
全肯定とか 一応辞書が入ってます
だから包括って言っても
そんなにこの 悪い言葉ではないんですけど
この一掃する表現 何だかんだも一掃する表現っていうのは
このいい加減に使ってはいけない
大雑把 大雑把に  まあそうですね
大雑把ということですね
しかし これも大雑把で包括的でスイーピング取ってはいけないんです
これ この言葉さえも なぜならば
これ使わなくちゃいけない時もあります
だから この言っただけではい
わかりましたということはよくないんです
私は何を言いたいんですかというと
物事を明確に分析して
分析して して 究極的にいくと
例えば人生は苦しみの連続ですかという問題ね
ずっと分析してみると
横と縦にはいろんな色の配列があるでしょうに
それはあまりにも何 10万も色があると人生に対しては困るんですね
苦しいか楽か 何かも言えなくなっちゃうでしょうに
しかし スペクトラムというものを見てください
人間に見える色っていうのはもう 3原色 3
つしかない そこは組み合わせて組み合わせて何 10万色も現れるのです
黄色いと何でしたっけ？赤と青と青
だからこのコンピューターででもたくさん色を出せますよ
しかし このコンピューターは機能的に 3原色ですよ 3
つしか持ってない それで色っていうのは三つしかないんだよというと包括的なんです
これ間違ってるわけじゃないんです
しかし そうやって包括的に一掃して表現できるなのは
きちんと研究した人なんですよ
でないとできない それで我々は何も研究もしないで
いきなり包括的に水平で全部一掃して何か言って
それでも無気力に無能に無知な人間になってしまう
それでわかりますか？言いたいことは
だから ただ簡単にマジですかとか何とかで終わるんじゃなくてね
人生は苦しみの連続だよと言ったところで
はあ わかりましたということではなくて
チャレンジしてみる 本当ですか？と
楽しみもあるんじゃないかと
そのチャレンジしたところで
あらゆる無数の経験が現れるはずなんです
つまらないと言ったっても
つまらなさというのはたくさんある
大変と言ったっても 大変さはたくさんある
苦しいと言ったっても
いろいろの苦しみがあると
これで無限に人生って何なのかっていうものは出てくる
これでやりきれなくなっちゃうんですよ
それが智慧なんです なんだ
人生って もういろんなものがあってどうにもならんと
そこで最後にその人はでは何なのかと分析するんですよ
そこで何万色も我々の目に見える色があるんだけど
よくよく科学者が分析したところであるのは三つだよと発見する
それが包括的な表現で
それがファイナルアナリシスということになるんです
最後の分析 それで人生は苦しみの連続ですというのは
お釈迦様のこのファイナルアナリシスで
最後の分析で そう生半可な智慧でわかるものじゃないんです
そういうふうな順番を踏まないと
人生っていうのはもう何も成功しないんです
だから今日の話はもう人生諦めている人にとっては
もうちょっとどうにもならんかもしれません
そこまで言うならば やってみるんではないかと
といういくらかエネルギーが残っているいないと
だからこれが一応若い若い人と狙って若い人に嫌われるかもしれませんだけど
明日死ぬ方ででも これ一日でやればいいんです
それで何か発見するんです
死ぬ瞬間まではよかったと行って死ねるんです
だから私は年だから ちょっと若い人の方が自分にとってはやりがいがあるんですね
だから言ってることは何時間でも何年間でも
その人々は死をするんじゃないかなと
その人々の子供たちもその影響を受けるのではないかなと
ということで あの 木の実を取って食べるよりは
種を植えることが意味があるんだと
桃 桃 桃ですか 桃を取ってそのまま食べるっていうことは美味しいんですよ
確かに でもそれで口を洗って手を洗っちゃえば終わりますからね
でも桃の種を植えておくと
結構仕事はありますよ
やるやる やりがいもあります
面倒見なくちゃいけないし
虫が食ってるかないか見なくちゃいけないし
それで花が咲いてくると楽しいし
それでいろいろそういうことで
この ですが あの普通に皆様にも
どんな方にも 明日死ぬ予定の方にでも
こういうあの 一応チャレンジした方がいいんじゃないかなと
人生に そこで まあそれで生きがいなんです
立派な生きがいなんです
ただ 無批判で無分別で
ただなんとなく馬鹿みたく細胞だけ生かしてるんではなくて
ちょっと見る何がこれは何やと
人生って何なのかと見てみるってことが立派な仕事なんです
で こちらで次に書いているのは
この生きがい 希望なんか見出すことできる人は
もう耐えがたいほどの苦しみにも出会っても生き抜くことができるでしょうと
これがちょっと異論はあります
でありますけど まあ例えば私はこのことをやりますと
こんな目的ができてますと
こういうことにチャレンジしますと
何か目的が出たら 世の中ではみんな苦労はあまり気にしないんですね
これは俗世間のよくよくあることで
オリンピックに必ず出ますと思う若い人だったら
もうどんな苦労もしてもう訓練はする
で なんでしょうかね あの
まあソ連のちょっとした番組を見たんですけど
このあの このバレリーナ学校でしたっけ？ソ連っていうのは厳しいんだから
基準は そこでいろんな学校から試験受けて落ちて
落ちて落ちて落ちて落ちて
最終的にはまあ10人ぐらいの女の子たちがもう学校に入るし
これでも世界的な有名な
まあ元バレリーナの先生方に指導されると
朝から晩まで まあ訓練は訓練はもうよく生きてるんでしょうかと
この女の子たちはと思いますよ
あれを見るやら何回見ると
その上 あなたの体重が重すぎだと
だから表現がよく出てこないんだとかね
手を伸ばしたら その先生がもうあんた飛行機ですかと
と怒るんですね だから彼女がもうプロのうちプロだから
もうそのような飛行機な感じで踊ってみせると
もうやっぱりとわかるんですね
やっぱりこれがかっこ悪いんだと
そこで手を伸ばしても
滑らかにこの美しい線を描くようにと
微妙なところ 指先までもう厳しい
そこでゆっくりと滑らかに曲げないと
もう怒られて もうもっと体重減らせと
体重減らといったら もうもうもう今の体重がないんですよ
もう朝から晩まで運動して踊らなくちゃいけない
指先で立っていなくちゃいけないしね
それで食べないんですよ
一人がリンゴ 1個だけで
一人がもうほとんどもう 1食
それをほんのちょっと食べて水だけでとかね
で 考えてみてください
あれほど労働して その上食べることもしないでいると
信じられますかね？その苦しみが
しかし そういう女たちが
やっぱり国家試験があるんだからね
で 頑張るんです なぜ頑張るかというと
やっぱりこのその試験合格したいと
それでプロの世界に入りたいと
だから そのような何か目的ができて上がっちゃうと
人間というのは苦労っていうのはね
全然もう全くもう気にしないんですね
だからみんな自分にも何か今日の説法でもそういう目的でも何か教えてくれるんではないかと思ったら
これ勘違いで 自分の目的は自分で探さなきゃ
それが私が言ったっても
親が言ったっても 何の意味もないでしょうに
それでみんなあなた言うことわかるんだけどわかりませんって言うんですね
どうすればいいかと 冗談じゃないでしょうに
母親に言えますかね 自分の子供に
君の目的はこれですよと
君はこういうことのために生きてみなさいよと
これに命を懸けろと言えるんですかね
母にも父にもできんことを
これが自分で発見しなくちゃいけない
そこでおかしい人々はおせっかいする
あなたにはこれだ あなたにはこれだとかね
でも人のことを親切に思う人がそれは言わないんです
こうしなさいと だから前言ったように
この物事をちゃんとデータ取って
人生は苦しいか楽しいかとかね
そういうふうにデータを取っていくと
すぐ道が見えてくるんです
人生の生きている間で
小さなパズルの小さなあれ
ピースが見つかるでしょうに
そのピースを一つ一つ
何色か どんな形かとかね
これは見て見ていく間で
このピースをつなげられるようになるんですよ
それで あ なるほど これはこういう絵だと
それで欠けてるピースを探せるんです
簡単に だから 1個も自分の人生というジグソーパズルのピースを 1個も見つからないで
なんとか教えてくれと言っても
なんともできんですよ
だからこの物事にチャレンジするということがあると
自分の人生というものの
このジグソーパズルの小さなピースを一つ一つ見つかるんです
毎日 こう毎日見つかるものはちょっとつなげてみると
あ なるほど こういう絵柄だよと
残りは推測でできます
それで欠けてるピース見つかればいいんです
そこで完璧な幸せな人生ということになるんです
では いくらかこの説明しますけど
この例えば自分が何か仕事をするやら
何かするやら 家で掃除洗濯するやら
何でもいいんです そういうことをやっている自分を観察してみます
自分が上手にやっているか
つまらないか 楽しくてやっているか
結果はどうでどうなったかと
その風に観察すると自分の能力見えてくる
それから自分をやったことはどれぐらいのパーセントで結果出すかとも見えてくる
それで自分が見えてくるんです
例えば やっと苦労してなんとか結果を出せたという場合もあります
ほとんど苦労しなかったのに
抜群にうまくいった時もあります
そういうのを客観的に見ない限りは
自分のジグソーパズルのピースを発見できんですよ
例えばやりたく やりたくてある仕事にチャレンジする
それで普通の人だったら
私はこれやりたかった仕事だ
幸せだという あまりにも馬鹿馬鹿らしいんです
あんたやりたかったんだからどうでもいいんです
そんなのは やりたかった仕事に仕事を見つかったんだぞとかね
大きな迷惑ですからね
仕事下手だったら だからそんなことはどうでもいい
自分ではやりたかった仕事に出会った
それで一つパズルなんです
ピースなんです 自分はやりたいことには出会うもんだよというピースなんです
それしかそちらの他何もないんです
それ全て人生だと思うのは勘違いです
それにそのやりたかった仕事をやってみる
やってみると大変苦しいかもしれません
でもやりたかったものだからめげない
それもう一つのピースなんです
やりたかったんですが
大変きついと そこで知恵ある人がやりたかったものっていうのは
必ずしも簡単なものではないんだと
その人に限って そういう風な次のピースを受け取ってみる
次に結果を見る 結果満足いけるものか
みんなに無視される結果かと
それぐらいですかね あんたやったのはと言える時もあります
あんたこれこれやるために 1 週間頑張ったんですか？と怒られる時もあります
こんな 30分の仕事なのにとかね
それで落ち込むんじゃなくて
自分がやりたかった仕事にはこれぐらい苦労しましたというパズルがあって
結果としてはこれぐらいやと
そのパズルのピースがあって
それつなげてみてください
そうすると で 答えはどこにあるんですかね
ということは やっぱりこれが
この道はものすごい苦しみの多い道であるという
結果が少ない道であると
はっきり見えるでしょう
自分の人生設計で そのピースつなげれば
そこでその人は元のピースに戻る
やりたかったことには出会いますよと
では 次の選択に行けばいいでしょう
次に何をやりたいんですかと
で それ必ず出会いますからね
そこを同じく客観的に見てみると
あ これが楽ちんやとわかるかもしれません
楽ちんなんです もしかすると結果0かもしれません
これはダメやと他人から言われるかもしれません
かもしれません その場合
またそのピースつなげてみる
それで楽ちんな道なんですけど
自分もやりたい道なんですけど
しかしなかなか結果は出てこないんだという
で また自分にもまたやりたいことに出会いますからね
それでいつでもやりたいことに出会うんじゃなくて
その人はではあまりやりたくないものにもやってみたらどうですか？と別なピースを取ってみる
やりたくないものを選ぶ場合は不思議な心理であります
やりたくないものを選んだ場合は
例えば仕事の場合は収入はいいんです
必ずも 収入はいいんだけど
やりたくないという それが自分にはできる
でも面白くない それでわがままで面白い
やりたく やりたい仕事を探すんです
そこでやりたい仕事はあるんだけど
収入はない 若い人々に聞いたら
ほとんど 90%音楽家になりたいんですね
女の子に聞いたら みんな歌手になりたい
やってみなさい みんな
飢え死になるんですけど
10万人に 30万人に一人しかなれないんだから
もっと少ないでしょ 本当にプロの人々
でもみんなやりたい タレントさんになることとかね
だからやりたい仕事っていうのはあまりにも険しくて
収入が0の道 ほとんどの場合はあまりやりたくないものには日々収入が入るんです
そこでやりたくないものにもものもやってみる
そうするとやりたくないっていうことはあるんですけど
仕事は楽ちんだとかね
抜群な結果があるんだと
それでまた収入もあるんだと
要はそのパズルをつなげてみるピースを
それで結構いい結果が出てくるでしょ
自分に気に入らないのは 1個のピースだけなんですね
...全くはないんだとか
面白くはないんだと そこは変えちゃえば
面白いというピースに入れ替えれば
これでもう人生のパズルが出来上がっているんです
だから そういうふうに自分で発見するんですよ
自分で発見するためには
この観察能力なきゃ 智慧がなければもうどうにもならない
だから人間でなきゃできないんです
私はすごい厳しい失礼言ってはいけない言葉を言うんだから
このもうこの強情も捨ててくださいと
先進国だとかね 知識の国だとかね
何だとか 国はそうかもしれませんだけど
国の生きている人間っていうのはまだ原始人だと言いたいんですね
まだ動物の中にいるんだぞと
東は西もわからへんのよと
原始的な人間がどんな最先端の社会にいたっても
もう最悪ですよ 生きていられないんです
だから結局は人間っていうのは生まれるとき原始人で何もできん
それで生まれてから 我々はこの物事を見る観察能力
何でも鵜呑みにしない
自分で探してみるということをやってもらわなきゃ
もう人間にはなれない
ただの細胞の塊なんです
母親は細胞の塊は作ってくれる
この細胞の塊に命を吹き込むことは自分でしなくちゃいけないんです
仏教はそのための教えなんです
だから このわからなくなるほど無双に分析してあげたりもします
それから 例えば人生は楽かといったら
仏教から見ても一概に苦しいやとかね
楽やとかもう言ってないんです
これはもうものすごいスペクトラムというのは
横と縦にはかなり幅広いんだと
それでこの無双に分析したしてから
包括的などれぐらい基本的にありますかと
そこで残念なことに 経典にあるのはこの包括的な文章ばっかりだから
まあそれにいきなり乗っていろんな誤解するだけで
足がもうこけるだけで
本当の教えがわからなくなっちゃうんです
それをお釈迦様は 1 行で注意しているんです
自分で探せと 例えば人間なんで失敗するんですか？と言えば
理由っていうのは無双に無限大にあるんです
なんで人間失敗するんですかね
無限大に原因がありますよ
だから自分の人生でそれチェックするんです
なんで私は失敗したんですかと
それでまたいい加減な大雑把な人は
私はあまり失敗したことがないんだよと
いきなり言う それは私はあんた無知やと
もう人間ダメ 人間じゃないんだとすぐ言うんです
言わないんだけど そうと終わっちゃう
私がそうと終わったら
もうあれはかなりきつい言葉なんです
相手にしないんだぞということ意味なんです
もし言ったことで 私はいきなり何かとんでもない攻撃的なことを言ったり
ぶん殴るような言葉を言ったりしちゃうと
これはもう相手を受け取っているんです
同格で では出て来いと
そういうことで この私は全然失敗したことはないんだぞとか言ってもね
それは意味がない 失敗っていうのは
この我々思っている失敗っていうのは
この大胆にショックを受けたことだけなんですよ
これまた無知な人のやり方で
厳密に物事を見ない人のやり方で
大胆な失敗が起きちゃうと
ああ 失敗しましたと落ち込んじゃうんです
そんなもんなんじゃないんですよ
四六時中失敗してるんです
朝起きてから寝るまでもういろんな失敗あるんです
数えられないんです そういう小さなピースが人生のパズルのすごく大事なんです
お茶を入れようと思ったところに失敗する可能性あるでしょうに
こぼしちゃったとか あれはお茶っ葉入れてる割合
蓋を開けたところで蓋を滑って落ちたとかね
それも失敗ですよ またあれ探さなくちゃいけないんだから
そこら辺で研究しないんだから
みんなもう不幸の塊になってるんです
人間が だから仏教では安らぎを求める人は
いわゆる出家者はね 森の中にいるんだと
一人で人間は行かないところにいるんだ
それぐらい人間のことを敬遠するんです
人間っていうのは まあ失敗だらけで
不幸の塊で 暗くて憎しみで互いに殺し合いばっかりやっていて
なんか互いに肉食ってるような感じですね
二人がいたら この人はこの人の肉を食って
この人はこの人の肉を食ってる
そうやって互いに食い争っている生き方だからね
だから仏道の人とはまあ結構です
逃げましょうということでは逃げてるような感じ
それぐらいが人間っていうのは
だからなぜそうなるんですかね
それで解決方法なんですけど
例えば失敗という言葉が取ってみると
大胆な失敗ではないんです
そんなに一般人が考えることだから
人間が考えることだから
ブッダが考えることじゃないんだから
ブッダが考えることから見ると
お茶入れる時でも失敗がある
ご飯食べようと味噌汁を食べようと思ったところで
何か失敗起こる可能性あります
そういうどうでもないって思うんだけど
それはすごく大事なんです
なぜ自分が味噌汁食べようとしたところで失敗しましたかと
なぜ口にご飯運ぼうと思ったところで
箸からご飯落ちたんですかと
それも失敗なんです 出かけようと思って
あ 鍵 あ 鍵どこでした？とちょっと探すと失敗なんです
あの 30 秒 あるいはあの 1 分
そういうふうに失敗をチェックするんです
そうすると限りなく失敗見つかるんです
原因も限りなく見つかるんです
数えられないほど でもその研究は本当は 1 日 2
日  1 週間で終了するんですよ
それで自分の人生のジグソーパズルのピースが見つかるんです
それで大雑把なことをまた私も言いますよ
例えば あの判断は間違ったんだから失敗する
遅く始めたんだから失敗したと
早く始めすぎて失敗しましたと
それ失敗いろいろあるでしょ
何かやろうとしたところで
やり始めたのは早すぎ
それで失敗しました あるいはやり出したのはもう遅くなって
遅く遅くなったと それで失敗しましたと
あるいは別なことに興味があったと
これをやっている最中で
例えば車を運転していると
そばに一緒に歩いている運転流れている車を運転している女の子はすごい可愛いと思ったと
可愛い女の子だなと ぶつかりますからね
だからその時なんで失敗しましたか？と
興味が別なところに行ったんだからでしょ
そういう大胆な事故ぐらいは失敗で見るんですけど
その大胆な命かける失敗する前に
お茶こぼしたことで勉強してほしいんです
味噌汁を食べようと思ったところで
ちょっとあの自分の服に一つ一滴落ちたことで勉強してほしいんです
そういうことで 例えば下着とかなんとかサッサッと着たとする
着てみたら これ裏返しですと
それは失敗なんです みんな平気でへっちゃらな顔して
また脱いでまた元に戻して着るでしょうに
これでダメです もう失敗しているんです
でもそんなもので人は死にませんでしょうに
１円も損はしないでしょうに
しかし そういう失敗で自分の人生すべてあるんです
人生っていうのはジグソーパズルで見るならば
そちらにもワンピースがあるんです
それを見つけてほしいんです
だから アホな人に無知な人にはこの道は実践できないんです
無知でも何が起こるか
自分の周りで全く無関心な人にはできない
だからいくらかこの元気でやっぱり調べてみるぞというね
それで この失敗の原因
無数にあって 興味が別なところに行って失敗する
遅くなって失敗する 早すぎても失敗する
一遍に 2つミスやろうとして失敗する
ちょっと仕事をやってる最中で腹が立ってしまって失敗すると
突然何か別な出来事が起きて
自分に関係ないんですけど
それで自分の仕事を失敗すると
あらゆる失敗が原因があります
それで失敗ない人生と言えば
無数の原因なくそうと思っちゃうと
これ事実上無理なんです
ここで無数の失敗の中で
次に最後にまたフォーカス的に基本的な失敗って何なのかと
不幸になる原因はそれがお釈迦様以外誰にも言えないんだから
お釈迦様はすべて研究なさったんだから
お釈迦様はこの無数に数えられないほどの無限大にある人間の失敗の原因を全部まとめて三原色ですよと
貪瞋痴だよと言ってるんです
それだけ聞いてわかったと思ったら
これは勘違いでわかったもんにはなりません
それで自分で試してみる
探してみる なぜお茶を入れている蓋が滑っていったかと
それも失敗ですと その瞬間に原因見えてくるはずなんです
だからそれを気をつける
注意する それで失敗ない人生っていうのはできることです
そういうことで この生きがいっていうのは自分で発見する
自分で発見するためにも
そう この神様にお願いして
あるいはくじを当たってあみだくじで発見するものじゃないんです
母に聞いてやっているものでもないんです
学校の先生に聞いてやるものでもないんです
自分で自分を観察して
自分の人生のこのパズルのピースを発見して
で それからつなげていけばいいんです
で それでも人間失敗 それでも人間はうまくいかないんだから仏教なんです
例えば今ソ連の例で出したように
このとにかくバレリーナになりたくて頑張っている女の子たちがね
これはあの巨大なソ連ででも 10人 20人しか選びられませんだから大変なことなんです
それでその人々やら親やら喜ぶでしょう
おそらく あの巨大な国で
も選ばれた何人かだから
でもよくよく考えてみると
ただのただかな高段なんていうのか
バレリーナでしょ 体ひねったりねじったりいるだけでしょう
それで見る人々は面白いとかかっこよかった
それで終わっちゃいますからね
それぐらいのことにそこまで苦労するんですかね
まあ給料はもらいますけど
もしかするともっと少ない苦労で
もっと抜群に金儲かる人々もいますからね
このバレリーナさんよりはその楽団やらそういうものはマネージメントやっている人々はもっと金儲かっていますけどね
だから日本でも同じことでしょうに
このものすごい有名なもう芸術家の若者っていうのは
もうかなり売れてかなり金持ちなんですけど
その人を雇って入ってる会社がもっと金儲かってますけど
あのヤクザみたいな社長にはもうもう比べられないほど比べられないんだから
収入は ですから このそういう風にも考えてみたら
そこまで生きがい見つけても
命かけてまでやっても
結局何になるかと 命かけて頑張る生きがい見つけたら
もうどんな苦労でもするぞと言っても
もうちょっと考えてくださいと
もうちょっと考えてくださいと仏教は言うんです
それで仏教はもっといい生きがいは教えてはあります
次 次にこの文章にあるのは
このところが すべての物事は変化して由来できますから
生きる目的を固定して持ち続けることは決して容易ではありませんと
その時どうしますかと
もし何か目的を見つけても
物事は変化するんだから
やっぱり生き続けるべきかないかまた決めなくちゃいけない
例えばもう野球選手になったんだけど
まあ怪我しましたと もう治らないんだ
言っても苦労して野球選手でいるんですかね
例えばピッチャーだったらこの肩
もう肩の骨が壊れたんだと
あの関節にあるこのすごい大事な筋肉あるでしょ
あんなのはもう切れちゃうと切れたまんまだからね
もう元にも戻れませんしね
そういうのは切れたとかなっちゃう
もう肩は元に戻らない
それでもピッチャーで生きられますかね？じゃあ生きていられないんですね
だから物事は変化するんだから
たとえせっかく見つけたんだけど
どんな苦労してもやろうと思っても
やっぱりどうかわからないんですよ
うまくいけるかないかとか
そういうことだから やっぱり変化に応じて頑張るかやめるかという判断は自分でしなくちゃいけないんです
でも 弱い人はもうやめても未練があって
未練があって 残りの人生はもう不幸にしてしまうんですね
だから いくら自分の目的が見つけても
やめなくちゃあかんと思ったら
きれいさっぱり忘れてやめるということが必要なんです
わからないね どう どう
どうなるか 何が起こるかっていうことは
それで全く希望が持てないほどの苦境に陥っても
人生を投げ出さずに生き抜くことの意味は果たしてあるのでしょうか？と
で そこで一般的に見てみると
生きることの意味っていうのはないんですよ
例えば苦境に陥っても
国境ですか 苦境 え？ 苦境ですね
苦境ですね  苦境 苦境に陥っても
人生は人生を投げ出さず生き抜くと
そんなことやったって何か意味があるんですか？意味がないんです
どんな苦境を乗り越えてバレリーナになったんだよと言ったっても
飲めない食えない人生って何なのかと
結婚もできないとか 何を得られるんですかね
そういう人々はね そういうことだから
やっぱり意味がないんですよ
それでお釈迦様がそれが虚しいんだから
幸福の道を教えますよと言って
この智慧の道を教えるんです
言っていたのはそういうことなんだ
だからこの日々のことを観察してみなさいと
大胆なことではなくて
この単純なこと 単純に毎日の生き方
それ観察している自分も見えてくる
自分の感情 自分のアプローチ
自分の判断能力 そういうものも見えてくる
それで自分が自分を発見したことになるんですよ
それには意味があるんです
自分を発見していないならば
何をやってもバカバカらしくて無意味なんです
例えば 自分を発見しない人がもうありったけの財産を自分で儲かるのは
ただのフンゴロガシの虫やとお釈迦様は言うんです
あのフンゴロガシって虫がいるんです
糞は詰めては詰めては置いておく
結構大きく作るんです
いくらの糞のあれ大きくたっても
ただの糞だからお宝物にはならないんです
だからこの財産はお釈迦様がこのそれに例えているんです
で 人間 自分を発見しない限りは
世の中でありったけの財産
自分の手に入っても ただ無意味に死んでしまう
死んでいくんですよ たとえバレー界になっても
イチローみたいな イチロー言ったらダメですかね
あの松井です 松井みたいな
もう能力ない人はあまり言いたくないんですけど
能力本当にある イチローみたいにね
もうもう野球選手になったってもね
結局それで人生ですかと
だってイチローのことは日本人があまり好きじゃないんだから
これもその人わかってるでしょ
能力ある人のことを嫌われるというね
ただ 神様みたいに仰ぐ立てる人が必要なんです
万々歳と この韓国 北朝鮮人って何も変わりがないんです
万歳万歳と言って立ってるように
こちらでも誰か誰か誰かを作りを立ててよく安定
まあこれはこちらの感情だからね
まあとにかくその人のことは
松井がアメリカへ行くまでは NHK で放送してたんですけど
松井が行った途端もうイチローで誰？っていう感じなんですね
だからその本人から見ればね
どうでしょうかね 松井もまあ下手ってわけじゃないんですけど
まだまだ若いんだからね
もっと研究で頑張ってほしいという親の気持ちはないわけがないんですけど
まあやっぱり一人で自分の道を発見するというイチローと比べると
イチローの方が本当にモデルになる人格なんですね
だからそうなって 私はイチローにケチをつけたいんですよ
イチロー選手がもう天才的に野球選手なんですけど
それでどうかなと それで人生ですかと
結局他の誰とも同じで仕事をして
それから年取ってもう死んでしまうと
いくら能力あったっても
まあ年取るとね もうできなくなるでしょうね
あの速さっていうのはずっとあるわけないでしょうね
あのボールなんか取る
あれ見るともう驚くんですからね
あの速さと瞬間の判断と
でもいつまで持てますかね
それ そのスピードと速さって
やはりスピードとこの体力っていうのは
で アメリカにいたこのものすごい有名なこのレスラーがね
あのキャシウス・クレイという名前で
後でイスラム教になった
モハメド・アリ すごい傲慢
傲慢と言ったって あれはスポーツ選手として言ってる言葉ですけど
まあ怒鳴りつけるは 人を相手を馬鹿にするは
ものすごい状態にいたでしょうに
いつでもまあベルトを取るは
無敵のボクサーでしたけど
それで今どうですかね
まあ年は年でいいんですけど
この間どこかオリンピックでアメリカでやったところで
このあの聖火をつけ取るためにその人行ったでしょうね
あれ取れないんですよ
テレビ手がガチャガチャガチャガチャガチャ動くんですね
あのパーキンソンで だから立っていられない
彼が何を得たんですかと
だからベルトって何の意味ですかね
ただ飾り物 それでお金もらったんではなく
これはそんな苦労しなくてもみんなお金持ってるでしょうに
他の人とか もう何も能力ないブッシュさんがもっとすごい金持ちでしょう
大学入学できる能力なかったと本に書いてあるんです
でも私は読んでいる本なんですけど
その本にこう書くんです
しかし あなたの名前はブッシュだから
イェール大学に入りました
と そこまで侮辱されてるんです
それでお金だったら その人よりもあるし
怖いことをね だからこのベルトって何なのかとね
ただの飾りもんで 死んじゃったらすぐ意味なくなっちゃうでしょ？だからそういう生きがい
目的っていうのは見つけても
結局人生虚しくて無意味で終わっちゃうんですよ
だから何か別な変わらない目的
価値ある目的を見つけられなくちゃいけないんです
そういうことだから この俗的なことには
このどんな苦境 苦境に陥っても
人生投げ出さず頑張るってことは
ここまでは頑張らなくてもいいんですよ
そこまで生き とにかく生きにくそうとか
やめろと そんなに大変だったら
人生は短いんだよと仏教は言いたいんです
どんな苦労してでも 全財産捨ててでも
このベルト この賞 このトロフィーもらいますよと
だったらやめなさいよ
命もかけて 例えばプロレスラーとか何とかやってね
意味がないんだと やっぱり仏教の仏教から見れば
自分の人生設計っていうのは
生まれた時から死ぬまで全部うまくいくように設計しなくちゃいけない
俗世間では ある一時的で何か一つうまくいけばいいというふうに思っているんです
これだけうまくいけばいいんだぞと
だからみんな年取っていくと
もうつまらない つまらないって
あんまりにもつまらない人生になっちゃうんです
社会から追い出されちゃうんでしょう
なんででしょう 本当はこの年取った人々がたくさんいるということが
ものすごい幸福でしっかりした国になるはずなんです
でも 日本の社会はこれがすごい問題だと
迷惑だと 言ってるんです
自分にもそうなる 自分もそうなるなのに言ってる人々も
これがものすごいおかしいんです
元気だったら 頭があるならば
手にいろんな能力あるならば
そういう人々の仕事できるでしょ
若い者よりも だからみんなの思考が正しければ
日本の人口が老人化になっていることによって
さらにさらに豊かになるはずなんです
でも思考が歪曲されて変だから
もう年金ももらわないという状態に
みんな元気だったら年金なんかもらうもんかと思うぐらいで元気でいなきゃあかんでしょうに
この 55 67飛んでる人々のあの能力
どこ行ってるんですかね
あのリーダーシップはどこ行ったんですかね
今まで築いた世界をね
これ自分たちで築いたものでしょうに
あの腕はどこ行ったんです
何ですかね この生き方っていうのは
だから結局インチキではなかったんではないかと私は言いたいんですよ
ただ あの松井さんを神様みたいな感じで仰ぐような感じで
そうするとその人を演じるしか人生がなくなっちゃうんです
あの周りがなくなっちゃうと何もできない状態になってしまうんです
やっぱり人生は一郎みたいにならなきゃ
報道したくてもしなくたっても
俺がやるぞと 自分の問題だと
ですから この 人生設計っていうのはやっぱり死ぬまでしなくちゃいけないんです
ある一つだけ狙っていけるもんじゃないんです
ということで 次のポイントは終了します
えーと まあお釈迦様はどのように答えますかというのも
それをお釈迦様の答えも説明しました
で 私の話はこれからなので
これは宣伝の説明だけでね
一旦ちょっと休憩いたしましょう
はい じゃあ休憩 10 分間休憩して
それで まあ一つはお釈迦様の言葉なんですけど
ヤタサンカーダナスミンウッジタスミンマハパテ
パドマントッタジャエータ
スチガンダンマノーラマ
エワンサンカーラブーテス
アンダブーテプトゥッジャネ
アティローチェティパンニャーヤ
サッマーサンブッダッササーリプッタ
で これあの直訳 これあの
護因尼経のテーマに当てはめなくちゃいけない言葉ですけど
ヤタっていうのは たとえ例えばということで
サンカーラダーナスミンという長い言葉がありますね
それはこのゴミの山って意味なんですね
ゴミ捨て場 ゴミが溜まっているところ
ウッジタスミンっていうのは
まあまあ 何て言いますか
放棄というか この投棄というか
まあいい加減にあのゴミを何も遠慮なくポイポイと捨てたところ
ウッジタスミンというのは
このものすごいいい加減に捨てるという
ちゃんとゴミを処分するんじゃなくて
持っていっては捨てる
持っていっては捨てるという
サンカーラダーナスミン
そのようなゴミの山 どこにあるかというと
マハーパテ 道路のマハーっていうのは大きな
パタっていうのは道 すごい大きな道路のそばにみんな捨てたい放題ゴミを捨てていると
そういうゴミ捨て場がある
そちらにパドマントッタジャエータ
パドマンっていうのは蓮の花
タッタっていうのは そこにそのゴミの
まあ蓮の花が咲くことだから
まあ泥でしょうしね ものすごい汚いでしょうし
で パドマン 蓮の花がたったそこにジャエータ
生まれてくる しかし この蓮の花はスチ
それがすごい綺麗です
例えばこのゴミ捨て場に
このもう日本で考えちゃうと
この あのもう燃えないゴミばっかり捨てるんだから
冷蔵庫やらね そういうものじゃなくて
もっと汚いもの 腐れものを捨てたと思ってください
そうすると悪臭でもう近寄れないぐらい
しかし その泥のゴミの中で土綺麗な
ガンダムというのは香り
ものすごく綺麗な香りを放つ
マノーラマンというのは美しい
目が喜ばせてくれる 蓮の花が咲くんだよ
ゴミの山でゴミはもうもう見たくもない
汚い 次の行 エワンサンカーラドゥーテス
サンカーラドゥーテスアンダブーテプトゥッジャネ
この上にあるサンカーラという言葉は下でも使ってます
でも下ではサンカーラっていうのは合成されているという意味なんですけどね
でもゴミにも使ってる言葉なんです
こういうのを合成されているアンダブーテ
目が見えないプトゥッジャネ
一般人の中であのゴミも合成するんだからね
生ゴミなんか捨てちゃうと
あの何合成って言うんですか
この化学反応いろいろ起こしたりして
肥料になったり臭くなったりしますね
で そのような言葉をお釈迦様は見事に使うんです
サンカーラっていうね
そのように人間もいろんなことを合成されてできてるんですね
それだけじゃなくて アンダブーテ
目が見えない人々 一般人がプトゥッジャナっていうのは一般人ということ
世の中の人々 世の中の人々はただ自分を合成している目が見えない人々の中で
アティローチャティ 美しき輝き
ものすごくもう乗り越えて輝るんだよと
アティローチャティ パンニャーで智慧で
誰ですか？サンマーサンブッダッササーロコ
サンマーサンブッダっていうのはお釈迦様のこと
ブッダのこと ブッダの弟子たちが智慧の光で輝いているんだと
それがお釈迦様がみんなに言っている道なんです
人間っていうのは もう人間の世界っていうのはゴミやゴミだと
もう合成されていて もう臭いんだと
その中で自分も臭くなるんじゃなくて
智慧で光り輝いてほしいと
蓮の花のように それはなんで書いたんですかというと
世の中でダンマパダの 58と 59 なんですけど
世の中で私たちは目標を作る場合は
自分を見ない 世界を見る
あの人のようになりたいと
いつでもその思考でしょ
だからいつたってもこの世の中はだらしないんです
あの人のようになりたい
あの人をモデルにしたい
だから 母親も母親でいつでも子供たちに誰かのようになりたいと言うんです
では その誰かさんが立派ですかね
知ってますかね 例えば私はイチローの名前出したでしょうに
私たちはテレビ画面で見ることしか知らないでしょうに
それはその人の人生のもう何万分の1にも値しないでしょう
何者かさっぱりわからないんです
性格はいい人か悪い人か
人格はできているかないか
何一つわからない 我々知っているのは
ただ作り出しているテレビ画面の映像だけ
それがその人のようになりたいと
いつもそんなもんで それでいろんな偉い人が自分の自伝書いたりするでしょ
自分で書くんだから悪いこと書くわけないでしょうに
悪いこと書いたっても
それを見事に面白く良いことのように書き換えるんですよ
ああいう失敗して良かったという風に思えるように
だから誰かの自伝なんか読んだっても
本当のことはわかるわけじゃないんです
テレビでちょっとした画面見て
全てそれやと決めるのはね
あまりにもおかしい あまりにも無知的
それで母親が子供にあの人のようになりたいと
テレビ画面で見えるこの人々の服装や
化粧やら見てあまりにもおかしいんですよ
あれが それでそのようになるとしている
あんなもんで生きていられないんだから
そこでそういう生き方ね
仏教はちょっとおかしいと
それで世の中は完璧な人はいるわけでもないし
自分人っていうのは何か目的があると
これ手段選ばずとにかくその目的に達するんですよ
この政治家なんてでも
どんな悪いことでもして
投票で選ばれて もう自分の議席を取りたいんですね
それで国民のために命かけて
正直で透明な政治で頑張っているんですけど
やったことバレるともう議員辞職しなくちゃいけないんですね
バレるまでは本当に完璧な立派な人なんですね
私は昔から嫌な人がいて
髪の毛長くてね 議員じゃなくてどこかに暴力団でも入ってくださいという雰囲気でいたんだけど
最近もうバレてますね
それでももう何を弁解するんですかね
真摯だったらね 申し訳ない
私は辞めてやり直しますと
それだけのことでしょうに
いえ 選ばれた人々のも何とか果たさなくちゃいけないんだからという
だから辞めません 誰が選んだんですかね
もしそういう人々なら別に気にしないよと言うと思いますよ
投票した人々に聞いたって
それで国が滅びるわけでもないし
その人が選んだ地方の人々がそれで終わりということないでしょうに
だからその人を辞めたんだからといって
ひとかけらも日本の国に
その地方にはひとかけらも問題はないんです
ただいることが問題ですけど
だから真摯だったらやめれ
やめてまた選挙に出ればいいでしょうに
出たところで日本人というのは大体もう性格はね
まあいいんだから まあ可哀想やということでまた選ぶでしょうに
その時は嫉妬上で選ぶんだからね
問題ないでしょうに だからだらしない性格
もう人間のリーダーじゃなくて
どこかのゴミ収集する
どうでもろくにやるんでしょうね
そんな仕事にしかふさわしくないんですよ
私は最初からもう本当は気に入らなかったんです
なんかポッカリテレビで見る時も
まあもうこの人はおかしい
まだいます？私のリストに
で でも大勢の方々は別の意見だから言えないんですよ
で だからここでこの世の中やることやるんじゃないんです
あの人のようになるんじゃないんです
これでまた仏教でいい例えがあるんです
あの これ目蔵の例えで言った方がいいんですけど
目が見えない人の例えなんですけど
で まるっきり生まれつき目が見えない人がいて
その人には歩けないんです
それで杖を持っている
で その杖はもう一人の人が捕まっている
しかし その人にも目が見えない
生まれつき その人の杖はまた一人の目が見えない人が捕まっている
その人の杖はまた目が見えない人が捕まっている
そうやって目が見えない人のスーッと列が出来上がる
それであまりにも長いむちゃくちゃな列になると
このヘビ型になって どんどんどんどん一番後ろが一番前のところに行く場合もありますね
このいろんな催し物に列作るでしょ
そこで最後はどこですか？とジーッといって言って歩いて歩いて
2 3ぐらい歩いて歩いて
また元に戻ったところに
そこが最後ですね そういう場合もあります
そんな感じで 最後の人はもう前の人の杖を持っていて
自分の杖があるんだから
その杖は前の人に繋げてあげれば
そうすると進んでください
そうするとみんな前の杖取ってる人が歩くんだから歩くんです
どこへ歩くんですかね
こちらにいる目が見えない人は
前の人が行くように行けばいいと
前にいる人は前の人に行くように行けばいいと
もっと前の人は前の人に行くように行けばいいと
そうすると永遠にその人々は同じ輪でぐるぐるぐるぐるぐるぐるぐるぐる回るだけなんです
そこで輪はいろんな湾曲して
どんな湾曲があっても
見事にその湾曲からジーッと左
左に曲がるところはちゃんと左に曲がって
右に曲がるところはちゃんと右に曲がって
同じところでぐるぐる回っている
進むことはないんです
世の中の生き方はそんな生き方です
仏教から見れば 前の人にも見えないし
後ろの人にも見えないんです
だからあの人をやる通りにやるんだよ
何だこの考え方は 歴史的に考えたら
我々は前の人がやったようにやっているでしょうね
ありえないんですよ だから理性がないんです
歴史的に見ると 人間は最初は原始人で
猿みたいな生活していて
もうどんどん動物に生活するようになって
石でものを壊したり食べたりする時のそうやって石器時代があったりして
ゆっくりゆっくり成長したものでしょうに
ということは 私より前の人は私ほど知らないということことでしょうに
これ事実でしょう なんでそれを否定するんですかね
そこで自分の設計する場合は
見事に古い人々の道を歩もうとしている
自分の目標を立てる時も
もう古い人々の目標を真似ようとする
成り立たないんです それに
これがお釈迦様はそれはダメですと
ではどうすれば自分で目を覚ますしか覚ますしかないんです
自分で目を開けるしかないんです
自分で目を開けたら それは要りません
どこへ行くかと自分で決めればいいんです
だからお釈迦様が右に行け
左に行けではなくて 目を覚ませ
目を開けと言うんですね
そこで他の宗教やら他の人々はやはり聖典という神の言葉みたいなものを書いて
そこで頑固でそれを守って守りなさいと
神に言われたんだから守れという生き方を言っているんですね
だから この生きがいとか何とかという場合は
やっぱり自分の目を覚ます
目を開くという道しかないんですと
だから仏教って何なのかというと
自分の目を開く方法なんですね
だからずっと説明していたのはそういうわけで
自分で観察して人生を見てください
それが生きがいになります
それで問題は解決する
先輩の道を歩むんじゃないんです
だからそこでこの世の中でほとんどの人々は死んでしまいたいという人々いるでしょうに
みんな先輩の道を歩もうとしてるんですよ
親が引いたレールに乗ろうとしたんです
そこでうまくいかなかったところで
親にも嫌われて 学校でも嫌われて
友達にも嫌われて いじめられて
もうこんな人生は嫌や
死にたいんだと 自分で決めた人生だったら
死にたいという気持ちにならんでしょうに
だからこんな人生は嫌だ
死んでしまいたい 死にたいという
いう場合は 百パーセント先輩の道を歩んでいる人です
親が計画立てた道を真面目にやろうとする人々なんです
親の親で恐ろしいんですよ
もし親が自分がやったことを教えるんだったらいいんです
親が大工さんだったら
お前には大工の仕事を教えてやるぞと思ったら
それは具体的な経験だ
事実ことだから なんとか息子に伝えることできるんですよ
そこで大工さんやってる父親が息子に
お前は弁護士になれと
で 一生懸命金を貯ますと
塾に行かすと 言ったっても
自分でもやったことがない道だからね
それはもしかすると全部親が子供頃が弁護士の方がかっこいいやと思ったという錯覚はあるかもしれません
それで自分にはできなかったんだから
では息子に あるいは娘に委託するぞと
大体大体親っていうのは
まあそういう風に この自分にもできなかったこと
まあ子供に期待するんですけど
でもそこら辺でもフィクスズレてるんです
ただの動物的な感情 愛情っていうのはどうでもいいんです
みんな私に反対したい気持ちはあるかもしれませんだけど
そのみんななんで反対するか
これは動物的な感情のことなんです
自分の子供は可愛いと
やっぱり成功してほしいということは
これは動物的な感情であって
子供に対してはそれで幸せということじゃないんです
そういうわけで この死んで死に死にたいんだと
ぐらい人生嫌いになる人々の場合は
確実にこの 前の人々が編み出した妄想的な概念というか
目的目標を自分でやろうとしたことになるんです
だからお釈迦様はそれこういう言葉で
ブッダの弟子たちがそういうゴミの中で咲く蓮の花のようにいるんだよと
ゴミと蓮の花っていうのはまるっきり違うもんで
しかしあのゴミから栄養は受けている
受け取るんですけど 臭くはないんです
臭い泥の中なんですけど
花はすごい美しい香りでいられる
だから自分の目標を立てる場合は
やっぱりこのあの人のようになるんじゃないんですよ
自分 自分が自分だから
二人いないんだから 自分に等しい人は
輪廻から考えても同一人物二人がいないんです
一人一人がユニークなんです
それで自分が自分の目標っていうのを見つからなくてはいけないんです
それがすごい楽でしょ
自分で発見するものだからね
あの人のようになりたいということは結構苦しいんですよ
ペンギンで考えてください
ペンギンは私は鳥ではないかと
鳥といえば 鳥は飛ぶんだよと
それは世の中の常だよと
ペンギンが事実を語ってもね
いい加減にした方がいいでしょう
ペンギンは飛べないんだから
ペンギンは鳥じゃなくて
ペンギンはペンギンです
カラスも鳥じゃなくてカラスはカラスです
カラスも鳥なのに なんで文鳥みたいに可愛くなってくれないんですか？と言ったってもね
いくら頑張っても文鳥になりません
だから一人一人の生命がユニークなものであって
自分の道っていうものは当然ありますね
それを発見しなさいというのが
だから この小さなヴィパッサナーの破片をね
見つからなくちゃいけないんです
そこであの智慧というものはすごく必要ということにも
お釈迦様の言葉があります
えーと うーん これ色があった方が見やすいんですね
一応 間違った うーん   ...これも同じダンマパダの
百五十二番目の偈です
アッパスッタヤンプリソバリワッドワジーラティ
アッパスッタっていうのはもう何も勉強しない人のことなんです
ただ生きているだけの人々のこと
そこでこの学校に行って勉強したって
仏教は勉強だと思っていないということも覚えてほしいんです
勉強っていうのはやっぱり理解能力なんです
学校に行って得た知識情報を使えるかないかと
人生に使えるんだったら勉強した人
まあ例えば文学部出ましたと
それはただの紙で書いてるだけのことで
自分でそれが使えるか
その能力 ちゃんとかっこいい文章を書けるかっていうところは
もう使用実践できる能力
それが智慧の世界なんですね
だから勉強するということは
ただ本を読むだけことではないんです
それはわかるか 自分で使用できるか
自分のものになるかということですよ
だからそれがアッパスッタということで勉強していないという
していない人 アッパスッタヤン
あれ これちょっと切らなくちゃいけないんですね
プリソ この人はまあただ人を見て勉強もしていない
この人はバリワッドワジーラティ
バリワッダっていうのは牛
牛のように太るんだよ
体だけは マンサーニタッサワッダーンティ
マンサーニ 肉は タッサ
彼の 彼の肉はワッダーンティ
増えますよと そこまでは遠くないね
あとワッダーンティっていうのは増えるという
タッサ彼のマンサーニ
肉体だけは増えますよと
タッサ彼のパンニャーチーはナッワッダーンティ
増えませんと だから私最初に言った
このただの細胞を生かすだけではダメですよと
だからみんな体のことは随分気にするでしょうに
美しくいること 痩せること
綺麗な服を見まとうこと
上手なお化粧の塗り方
うん 癌にならない食べ物
そんなものばっかりでお釈迦様からは教えるんですよ
そんなのは何の意味もないんです
あまりにも軽視されているんです
お釈迦様に だから私はそういう芸なんか遠慮しないで言うと
すごい失礼なことを言うんだなと思うでしょう
結局前から見て このただ最後を生かしてるだけでは意味がないんだと
現代科学でもそんなことやってますよと言って
それなんです たぶん ですから
やっぱり人間の目標を立てる場合は
知恵っていうものを大事にしなくちゃいけない
観察しなくちゃいけない
学校に行って勉強するだけではダメなんです
この自分が今習っているのは何なのかと
これは使う道でもあるかと
どのように使えるかと
そういうふうに勉強しなくちゃいけない
例えば 何か人の話でも聞いた途端
あ これが使えるぞと すぐ頭に何とかひらめきが出てこないと
あ これがこういうふうに使えるぞと
それがないと知恵がないんです
で ついでに余談ですけど
私のものの見方はいつもそういうものの見方なんです
何でも見たり聞いたりはするんだけど
全部流すんです 止まっては起こりません
情報っていうのは通ってください
止まるなよと そこでなぜ通すかというと
使えるかないか 使えるかないか
それだけなんです あ これ使えるぞと思ったら
そこはストップしてもらう
はい 帰ってくださいと
入れないんです 頭の中に
だから本でも一回読んだら大体は二回目は読まない
もう入れるものは入れているんです
みんなこの本を勉強しなくちゃということで
全部初めから終わりまで読むでしょうに
それ 溜まるだけゴミが
それでゴミが溜まりすぎて
いわゆるこの整理していない図書館みたいで
もう一つも本が一つ見つからないんですよ
この皆様 図書館の中に入った経験ございますかね？あの本をガチャガチャにしてみてください
永久的になくなるんです
だから図書館の中には素人は入れないんです
素人がこの本面白いそうと見てどこかに挿しちゃうと
その本は永久的にないことになるんです
日本でね 一番大きな図書館というのはどこでしたっけ？国会議事堂図書館でしょ
誰も入れませんからね
しかし 誰でも使える あんなの中に皆様の一人でも行っちゃうとね
大損ですよ もうどうなるかわからない
自分が何も悪いことをしなくても
自分が探す本は見つからないはずなんです
だから勉強っていうのは
そう まああの整理していない図書館ですよ
大体人間の心っていうのは
だから勉強したことはしたんだけど
実際の人生では何もできない
だからほとんどの九十パーセントの日本の方々
大学出ているでしょ でも実際見てみると
私から失礼ですけど 私には中学生の能力を見えないんです
全然見えない だから私はもうすごい小さな図書館もろくにないも本もない
何もない大学で勉強したんですけど
ちょっと見方だけ変わったんです
勉強するものは使えるかないかと
だから私は科学は何も知りません
しかし たまたま医学の本も開けてみるわ
心理学の本も開けてみるわ
医学の それからまあ科学の本も開けてみる
さっぱりわからないんだけど
もうそれが手に入ったらもういろいろちょっと開けてみる
それで別に元々わからないんだから読むつもりもないし
しかし情報を流しちゃうと
あれ このこれが使えるんだぞと
そうやって何かポイント一つ使っちゃうんです
いろいろ科学の方から例を出すんだからといって
私は科学も勉強しているんだぞと
それはすごい勘違いというか
それは間違いなんです
何も知らない だからお釈迦様はそれがあってほしいと
ただ情報ばっかり集めても意味がない
だから情報は流しちゃえばいいんです
あ これ使えるぞと 使えるポイントだけ取ってみる
だから今日の話でも長い時間喋るんだけど
私はポイントとして一つ
二つ そこしかないんです
それ入れて伸ばして伸ばして喋るだけ
だから ちょっと鋭く見てみるならば
あ 今日はこのポイントやとわかりますな
私はそれ言いません このポイントやと
これ使えるぞ あるはずなんです
あります あって喋るんだから
で まあ一応あの まあだから人間っていうのは
あの大事なあのバレリーナになっても悲しい
一郎みたいな人になっても
結局は人生悲しい それ死ぬまでの計画ではありません
では 死ぬまでの計画だったらこれどうですかね？鋭い人間になってみる
誰の話を聞いても どんな本を読んでも
新聞を読んでも これ使えるかないか
それだけわがままでいいんです
アメリカの人口どれぐらいとか
そんなのを覚えなくてもいいんです
アメリカ人の収入はどれぐらいで
それはどうでもいいんです
自分に使えるかないかと
それで見ると みんな自分に役に立つ人間になっているんです
だからたくさんみんな
特に日本の方々 すごい本を読むでしょうし
だから本を読まない私から見れば
もう私は怖くて逃げるほど頭が良いはずなんですが
逆に私が見るとみんな逃げるんですね
なんでしょうかね とにかくみんな逃げる
時々冗談でちょっと何のことなく
まあただ元気ですかということを私は元気でしたと言わないんだからね
別な言葉で言うんだからね
これだけのことで怯えて逃げるんです
だから昨日あの名前を忘れてましたけど
あの若い子が来たでしょ
まあ結構仲がいいんですけど
私も別に ああ 君なんだ
コンパス壊れたのかと
それは私の元気ですかっていう挨拶なんです
それまたみんなすごいびっくりして緊張して
なんかどうなったんですかね
なんでそんなこと言われたんですか？と
もうもう付き合えないんで
それだったらもう 何のことない
ただ私は冗談で だから私はちょっとした物語で
人が森の中でいろいろコンパス持ってちゃんと道歩く
これコンパス壊れたらどこに行くかわからないんだから
ただたまたま来たんだから
まあもう来てよかったって意味なんです
だからそういうイメージネーションというか
面白さとかね それがないと人生ってつまらないんですよ
では 私はコンパス壊れたんですかということをまた 2度と使うと思いますか？もう 2度と使いません
だからそれぐらいっていうのはね
それほどたくさんの本を読んでいる皆様にないはずがないんです
そういうことで この冊しか本を読まない私は使えるかないかというわがままで読む
皆様はすごい 大きな心で読んでるんですね
知恵が膨らまさなくちゃいけないんだと
ものは知っておかなくちゃいかんと
結局は何も知らないんですけど
だから悲しい結果になっちゃうんです
死ぬ時でも虚しく死ぬ
会社退職したらやることがなくて
うろうろうろうろ 何やと
腐るほどやることがあるのに
私は悔しいので出家しているんだから
できないという やってはいけないということもうあるんだからね
あれもできるのに これもできるのにとかね
でも皆様には何の戒律も何の正義もないでしょうに
だからできることというのはものすごくいくらでもある
例えば すごい俗的に金儲けたいと思えば
それぞれ歳の人には歳の金儲けのやり方がある
歳の人には歳にふさわしい金の儲け方がある
それにしても これがだから人生面白いんですよ
美人でいたいと思ったらね
女性の方々は死ぬまで美人でいられますよ
知性 理性さえあれば でも誰も死ぬまで美人でいないんですよ
まあでもおばあさんで
おばさんでもなくて まあ正直に言うと
年はもうだいたい歳 歳ぐらい
だいたい年 年ぐらい古く見えるんです
本人はもう歳 の気分ですけど
あれ何ですかね やり方間違ってます
死ぬまで二十歳でいようとするのもあまりにもバカバカらしいでしょ
だから自分の美しさっていうのはその時その時変わるんですよ
だから形の美人と歳の美人が違うんですね
それに乗っていけば 歳ででも美人なんです
大山さんとか何とかという女性がテレビに出た
昔今は出てこない 亡くなったかな
すごい年のおばさん  小森さんえ？大山さん
なんかわからん 名前は当たりね
小森さん  小森さん なんかね
歳 歳ぐらいの女の子の服装を着てね
ああ それは それは大山
大山 大山  大山さん あれで美人ですかと
あんなものを見ると 男っていうのはもうもう何と言いますか
この拒絶反応のところじゃないんですよ
永遠にもう拒絶反応を起こすんですよ
女に対して それからこの女優たちいるでしょ？歳もすごい年配の
そういう年配の役をやっている
結構可愛いでしょ おばあさん役ばっかり任されてやっているね
歳の方々は だからそちらが役でやらなくちゃいけないんだから
そのちゃんと見事に歳を演じる
歳を演じる 歳を演じると
で 本当の年もだいたい
だから人間っていうのは本を読む時でも使えるかないか
だからこのわがままでいいんですよ
みんなのわがままは自己破壊的ですけど
仏教がおっしゃっているわがままっていうのは幸福の道なんです
すごい幸福の道なんです
で あのうまく見事にいくんです
だからあれがない これがない
人生はつまらない そんな言ってる暇があるんですかと
よくつまらないと言ってるなと思いますけども
日々物事変わっているわ
自分の人生がどんどん減っていくわ
死はみるみる 1日通ってくるわ
つまらないと ものすごいたくさんやることはいっぱいあります
そういうふうなことに頑張った方がいいんじゃないかなと思います
それでゲーでは
アッターナンチェピアンジャンガラッケイヤナンスラッ kitan ティンナンマンニャタランヤーナンパティジャッゲイエパンリトというゲーがあります
その意味は えーと 自分のことを好きと思うならば
よく自分を守ってくださいと喋りながらふた仕事できる
一応出します 時間はなくなりますけど
えーと  はい ...普通の気分だったら早く打てますけど
こう私はこのやっぱなんか使いたくないんだから
[笑い]好みの問題で
それだったら はい これ水分化のテキストだからちょっと
学問のところ全部ありますかね
あると思いますよ  ないみたい
最後まで  段階的に見てると入ってますけど
あ 段落 あ 大きい文字設定出します
そのテキストからこの必要なところだけ大きい文字にしたんです
アッターナンチェティアンジャンニャ
アッターナ自分のこと
チェ もしピアンジャンニャ好きだと思うならば
自分のことを好きだと思うならば
アッターナ自分のこと
チェ もしピアン好きだとジャンニャ思うならば
ナン それをいわゆる自分をね
ラッケイよく守ってくださいと
自分のことを好きやと思うならば
自分をよく守ってくださいと
ラッケイやナン スラッときたんものすごく
ちゃんと守ってくださいと
いい加減ではなくて すごい真剣に自己を守りなさいと
ティンナンマンニャタランヤーマン
ヤーマンというのはこの時間のこと
人間には時間 3つありますと
時間と言うんですかね
大きく分けて 3つ いわゆるこの若い頃
中年頃 老年というね  3つに分ける
時期です 時期  3つの時期があります
これ ティンナンヤーマン
ヤーマ 3つあります その中からアンニャタラン
いくついくつどちらでもいいんですと
パティジャッゲイヤ あのということは
ちゃんと手入れをし パティジャッゲっていうのはちゃんと手入れをして
綺麗に処理することなんです
直すことなんです ちゃんと自分を手入れをして
処理して直して しっかり作り上げなさいと
自分を作品にしなさいと
そこでいつやるかというと
この 3つの時期の中でいつでもいいんです
どういう意味かというと
例えば若い頃ふざけて悪い仲間に入って
もう人生はどうにもならなかったと
俗世間だったらその人は死ぬまでダメでしょ
若い頃 不良に走ってもうどうにもならなかったら
あんたは死ぬまで終わりやという
それで仏教というのは
じゃあ若い頃はあんた馬鹿でふざけちゃったんだったら
まあ中年のところでしっかりと自分をまた組み立て直して
磨き直してしっかりしなさいよ
では 若い頃もうまくいかなかった
中年の時も 仕事をする時でも
泥棒やったり悪いことばっかりしたとしたと
だったら老年の時期あるでしょ
その時でも直せと だから一回直しちゃえば残りは大丈夫だからね
だからこれが人生の目的にならなくちゃいけないんですね
やっぱりただ生きているんだから
そのままで逃がして逃げていくんじゃなくて
自分の人生を設計組み立てて作り直して
しっかりした人格を作る
そういうことをやってほしいと
あ またパティジャッ もうちょっと一部割にパティジャッゲイヤ
えっと パンディット あ
これまで入らないと切れてますけど
パティジャッゲッ パンディット
知恵ある人はパティジャッゲイヤ整理するでしょうと
パティジャッゲッルッカーとヨセフという英訳でね
自分の面倒見なさいと
だから本当は我々はご飯食べたり仕事をしたりしたっても
自分の面倒を見てないんですよ
その区別をわかってください
学校に行ったんだからといって
自分の面倒を見ているわけじゃないんで
ただ大きく大人になったら仕事は何するかという職業訓練だけなんです
ただ 年取ってから数字の勉強やらもう三味線の勉強やらね
そんなものをしたっても
自己の勉強じゃないんですよ
子供も大きくなって もう独立したところで
自分にはやることなくなっちゃうと
もうだいたいまあ男はゲートボール行くわ
もう女性の方々は社交ダンスか
まあ何か稽古事か何かに行って時間を無駄に使う
でもそれも子供の頃やることと同じことだから
子供の頃それやったって今虚しいでしょ
だったら年取ってやったっても結果は虚しいんですよ
子供の頃で勉強して ものすごく人生が明るくなったならば
その勉強は一生明るい人生を作ってくれるんです
だからただ勉強したり
三味線の稽古に行ったりするだけでは
人生はあまりにも暗い
あまりにも虚しい 表面的に元気かもしれませんだけどね
でもこのケースは認めます
例えばこの大学で昔見たんですけど
この結婚して家の仕事でももう何も勉強できなかったと
それが悔しくて それで子供から手を離したところで
早くも大学に入学する
入学して もう随分自分の子供と同じ年の若者なんですけど
一緒にチャレンジして勉強する
それが私はまあなかなかかっこいいなと思います
年取っているのに もう若者と一緒に入って勉強する
で その場合は自分には得られなかった何かね
知識をもう悔しいと 頭が悪くてダメやと
勉強したいんだと というならば
それはそれでは構いませんですけど
あのではなくて みんなやってるやり方っていうのはね
ただ時間はつまらない
やることはない だから社交ダンスに行くっていうのは
それもつまらない で 私はそのいろんな相談を受けた時は
この社交ダンス 料理教室
そういうものに行く この子育て終わったおばさんたちの間の話なんですけど
行きたくないんだと あのグループの中には
あまりにも性格が悪いんだと
見栄ばっかしを他人に見栄張るだけやと
私はこういうことをしているんだわ
私はこういうことをしているんだわとかね
だから地獄みたいな苦しみのために
何で行くんで それだったら
結局そのために行くんですよ
見栄を張って見栄を張って
自分を膨らませて すべての人に嫌われていただこうではないかと
家でも嫌われっぱなしで
子供たちにも嫌われて
旦那にも嫌われて これで足りません
それで料理教室に行って
そちらでも名前を知らないたくさんの人々に嫌われてもらうという
これで人生明るいんだと
私は歳 歳なんですけど
もう今料理教室に行って料理の勉強しているんだよ
そんなのは無意味な生き方なんですよ
それで人生はちゃんとあの...手入れしたことになりません
だから この 私に母親が言ったのは
いい人間になることですね
それが絶対的に大事 必要だと
いい人間になった上で
別に何やるかは別な話だと
学校の先生になるか 医者になるか
エンジニアになるか これは勝手にどうでもいいやと
何になってもいい人間になることが大事ですよと
勉強はまるっきりできなくても構いません
だからそれが土台なんです
いい人間になったならば
それから何やってもいいんです
それで私は私のところに来た男の子たちなんですけど
この学校で喧嘩をして先生殴ったりしてね
向こうはそんなことをしたらもう大変だから
日本みたいにこの優しくはないんだからね
で もう学校に行かなくなっちゃうんですね
先生は迎えに来ないんです
で 本人もやっぱり目上の人を尊敬する世界だから
一旦子供が腹が立って先生殴っちゃうと
まあ日本みたいに怪我するぐらいのことはしませんだけどね
大体この喧嘩して それだけでもね
先生にこの野郎なんとか言っちゃうと
それっきりでもう顔を合わせなくなっちゃうんですね
だから そういう子供たちなんか学校に行かないで来た時は
私はもう勉強できるかないかまず見たんですね
勉強できるわけじゃないんだと
それで心配 私は何を教えたかというと
信頼できる人間になること
それだけ教えるんです
これを教えると言ったっても
説教することではなく
一緒にいろいろ仕事をしたり
一緒に遊んだり いろんなもうお使いに使ったり
まあそれぐらいのことなんですよ
その間で で 頼まれた仕事だったらちゃんと果たすんだよと
人には裏切るというか
人に信頼できるようにならなくちゃいけないんだ
信頼は裏切ってはあかんと
そういうことはきちんと体につけるように教えてあげる
そういうのを人々はみんな大成功したんです
学校には行ってない 教育はなし
収入はあるんです 仕事は自分で探すんじゃなくて
仕事をあげたところで
もう逃がさないようにと捕まっておくんです
この人は別なところに行ったら困るぞと
それぐらい信頼する で
どれぐらいしっかりするかというと
私のだらしないところを見ても怒るんですね
なんでそんなことするんですか？と
で 私はもうわざわざでやっているんですけど
やっぱりそうやっても何もできないバカなガキがね
ちょっと体が伸びただけで
そんなことを私に言われると
それはものすごい内心で
ものすごい楽しいんです
顔には見せませんだけど
しっかりしているなと
あのお坊さんがもう私を今日は私すごい緊張するんです
私より年上なんですけど
私に何か言う時でも 私はすぐ返しに言うんだから
言う時にすごい気をつけていろんなことを言うんです
それである日 そうやって私が育てた男の子がいて
そいつはその どこかへ行けたかな
行かなくちゃいけないし
運転手がなくて もう運転頼むぞと言ったら
まあ私と仲良くできるんだから
その子もすごい喜んで
じゃあ行きましょうということで仕事を辞めてきたんです
自分の仕事を辞めて その日は来て
で 車に乗ったら まあ私はなんとかしたんです
とにかく こいつはいきなり私に怒ったんです
なんか車のことを あの人の車でもないしね
触ったら触るな 触るないって
で 私はそれで何のことなく手を
それは私の仕事 あんた方は座って行けばいいんです
これすごい失礼な言い方でしょ
それであのお坊さんの体でサッと汗が出た
私はこれ何するか分からないんだから
どうせ私の子だから やりたい放題だからね
私は何のことなくそうということで
何のことなくもう手を離して
別にあのお坊さんと他の話をしているんですね
そのお坊さんが言ったのは
スマナサーラを抑えるためにはこいつはないとダメですねと
やっぱりそれもその通りで
向こうはしっかりと人格できているんだから
もうどうにもならんですよ
何か言ったら まあそれはその通りであるということだから
はい わかりました かえって私はそれは嫌と思ったんだけど
全然逆なんです 私にとっても
まあ何と言いますか 目が高い
何て言います？その場合は頭が高い
鼻が高い どうだい？と
私のところにいた子供たちの性格はとという感じなんです
誰にもめげないんだぞと
ですから このやっぱりそれで
だから収入も 私は当時大学で教えていたって
私より収入はあるんですよ
学校に行かないで先生と喧嘩して辞めたのに
だから世の中生きるっていうことの方法というのは
いい人間になること それですべてついてくるんです
もしその人は日本に来たっても
もう支配下にいると思いますよ
もう行きたくはなったんですけど
私にしたっても もう完全に信頼できる人だからね
来たってもものすごい楽やと思いますけどね
何でもやってくれるんだから
自分のことだったら でもその子の奥さんがね
まあグーグーグーといろいろなことを言うし
やっぱりね で 私は怒ったんで
もういい加減にしろと
子供の面倒見なくちゃあかんではないかと
で それで何もやってあげなかったんですけどね
まあ家族のことを考えて
だからこの大事なのは何なのかというと
いい人間になること では仏教は何を教えているんですか？いい人間になることを教えているんです
ということはすべてを教えているんです
幸福のすべてを そこで
この三帰の中で一個だけでもいいんだからやってくださいということは
すごい希望的な教えなんです
もしお釈迦様は人生は性格は子供の頃作るもんだよと
１歳  ２歳  ３歳までは 西洋の心理学者が言うように
人間の人格はこの幼稚園の時
組み立ての問題と言っちゃうと終わりですよ
あれだったら あまりにも恐ろしい話で
仏教はそうじゃないんで
いつでも大丈夫だと 遅いということはないんだよ
だから この死にかけている人のところでも
仏教の人々は我々は見舞いに行くんです
で もう日本だからって
日本の方々は病気になったんだから見舞いに来てくださいと言っちゃうと
ちょっとがっかりするかもしれませんだけど
頼まれたら行きますよ
まあ中止できるんだったら仕事の中止までして
人が病気になって倒れて
もうすごいね 不安な状態でいるんだからね
でも我々の慰め方が随分違うんです
仏教の慰め方は死にかけている人にも叱るんです
怠けるなよ 怠けるんじゃないやと
弱音をはくんじゃないやと
なんだか体ぐらい病気になったんだからといって
いい加減にしろという態度なんです
本人が死にかけて死にかけているんだからって何だと
死なないつもりですかと
死ぬでしょう だからしっかりしなさいと
こういうことをしなさい
こういうことをしなさいと
だから 死の １時間前でも
その人には人格を作って
清らかな心で大事な宝物を獲得して死ねるようにしてやる
その時は死ぬ瞬間でもう悔しくはないんです
その人にも ああ よかったと
最後の １時間で心清らかにすることができてよかったと
一生ふざけていたのにと
一生悪事ばっかりやっていたのにと
でお釈迦様の物語の中である一人の人の話があって
このすごい性格が悪くて裏切り者で泥棒やっていたんです
泥棒といっても この家を破ってね
まあ人を殺してまでして泥棒すると
これでこのこの人が泥棒のグループに入ったんで
このグループはみんな親戚なんです
この人は仕事がないんだから
泥棒のグループに入ろうと思ってお願いするんですけど
泥棒は入れてあげないんです
お前嫌やで 泥棒っていうのはお互いに信頼していないとできないんだ
正直でないと泥棒できません
あなたは別の人だから信頼できません
正直かどうかもわからないんだ
ちゃんと勤勉に真面目に頑張らないと泥棒できません
でも この人は諦めないでずーっとお世話してお世話して
お世話して ずーっとお世話すると
料理やら洗濯から何から何までやると
もうしょうがなく入れたんです
で ある日 まあある家に泥棒に入ったところで
まあやっぱりみんな捕まっちゃう
捕まってもう処刑になる
処刑になって 王様は処刑
みんな処刑だと 人殺してるし
限りなく泥棒やっているし
もういて困ります だってもうその処刑する人がもう亡くなっているんです
で 誰をその仕事に就かない
お釈迦様の時代で このゴータラ国かどちらかわからないんですけど
まああんまりこのそういう仕事をやりたくないし
で 王様が困って 王様で言ったって刑務所のところの人が困ってどうしましょうかと
これ罰を与えたらいいんだけど
実行できませんと そしたら王様がいい案が出てきて
あなた方の中で人いたんですけど
一人がみんなを殺せと
それで私はその人を免罪にする
その代わりに で 仕事をあげる
言っても泥棒のリーダーからみんな断る
これはできません これはできません
それで この人は親戚でもなんでもないんだから
では私がやりますと 言って
あの人人殺しちゃった
首を切ったんです そしたら
あなた仕事上手ですからと言って
これからやってくださいと
給料までもらって仕事をもらって
それから刑務所でずっと生活しているんです
処刑に決めた人々の首を切るために
で いいことをして一つもないでしょ？人格もだらしないでしょ
裏切り者でしょ 何もできてないんです
でも その人はやがてすごい年取って
もう仕事を辞めさせたんです
もういいや 帰れと 人を殺さなくなっちゃったんです
2回 3回刀で刺すみたい
これは残酷やと 一発で首を切らなきゃあかんということで辞めさせたんですね
辞めさせて その日でやっと家に戻って
この人がまあなんかおかゆみたいなものを作って
まあ今日はちゃんと沐浴をして
ちゃんと気分いい気分でおかゆを食べそうと思って
それを用意していたんですけど
このもうサッソウソンジャかな
その人の家に この人は一度でもいいことっていうのはしたことはない
もうボロボロ老人になってやった仕事は人殺しやと
でも この人を逃がすわけにはいきません
人殺しやだから地獄に行けとか
とんでもない話や 助けてあげないと
言って托鉢に行ったんです
だから言ったら その人がこのお坊さんで
やっとお坊さんを見たんだと
生まれて初めて 今まで泥棒ばっかり見ていて
人殺しばっかり見ていて
やっていて で 私は まあ私はこのあげるものはないんだからで
自分食べようと思ったものは全部おかゆを差し上げたんです
それでそのお坊さんを見て
その人はすごく やっぱり人間には別な道があると
清らかな道もあると 心は綺麗にしなくちゃあかんということを教えてもらった
であのお坊様が尊者 サッソウ尊者がありましたけど
その人はその日で死んじゃったんです
死んじゃったんですけど
発作を起こし 死にましたけど
あのお坊さんを見てお布施したその瞬間から
それだけ頭に焼き付けているので
自分も捨てたもんじゃないんだと
立派なことをできたと
という充実感で死んでどこに生まれ変わったと思いますか？天国に生まれ変わるんです
だから 最後の瞬間でも遅くはないというのが仏教の立場なんです
だからがんになったんだから大変だと
我々は思わない 末期だ
治らないんだと だから何やと 1 週間ぐらいあるんじゃないのと
一週間あるんだったら
その一週間にチャレンジする
いい人間になること だから仏教は決して何一つも諦めないんです
だからやってみるためにも結構現金でなきゃダメなんですよ
ということで この良い人間になるということは
正常心理学的には喋りません
いつでもできるぞと そう
どうせ早いうちは一番ありがたいのは当たり前なんですけどね
だって清らかな心で長生きできてられますから
生きることはいかに楽しいかとわかるでしょ
その人は この世の中で生きることも楽しいやんと
いろんな不幸がある世界で
みんなもう悩んでいる世界で
みんな互いに殺し合いやってる世界で
お互いに憎しみ合っている世界で
穏やかでいると結構気分がいいんです
だからまた同じお経で
で ススカンワタジーラーマウェールニュースアウェーの今日は持ってきてないんですけど
ウェールニュースアウェーリノウェールニュースマヌッセースヴィハラーム
えーと ページが 我々は楽に生きているんだよと
怒りで苦しんでいるこの人々の間で
この世の中の世の中で
我々は何の怒りもなく楽に生きているんだよと
えーと これでさ その もう時間がなくなりますですからね
割の知ってる誰かいれば頼みますけど
百九十七とかそういう
百九十七  あ そう  百九十七と百九十八
うん サンガッパ あーそう
いろんな本から引用しているんだから
もう自らも大変 もう並べて書いてない
それあらゆる言語でダンマからありますから
全部揃って入れているんです
出ました はい この上ススカンワタジ
私たちはすごい楽に生きているんだよと
ウェーリネスアウェーリの怒りに苦しんでいる人々の中で
何の怒りもなく すごく楽に生きているんだよと
ウェーリネスマヌスエス
怒りの人々の中で ヴィハラーマアウェーリの何の怒りもなく
まあ楽だ楽だと だから初め一番できるだけ早く人格を作っちゃえば
ものすごく楽っていうことなんです
みんなまだまだできてないんだから苦しんでるだけですよと
これでみんな怒って憎しみで苦しんでいるのに
ほら見なさいと 私は何の苦しみ
怒りなく楽にいるんだよと
次のこれはこの別な言語なんですよ
ブッダのあれだと思いますけどね
やつすぐダンテだとかで
サンダンテ サラリーマンだから
それは関係 上の偈に関係ないんだけど
入れているんですね まあこれは学問的なことで
まあ取っておきます それで百九十八また世界規模になると
別のものです 小節って書いてあるんですけど
百九十八出ました ススカンワタジーワーマアートレスアナートラ
アートレスというのはいろんな精神的なことで悩んでいる人々
いわゆる病気な人々 人間は病気だと
みんないろんな心の問題で
病気で悩んでいるのに
私たちは病気がなくて楽しているんだよと
精神的な病気がなく アートレスマヌス人間は病気だよと
精神的な欲やら怒りやら憎しみやら嫉妬やら
そういうものでもう病気だよと
そこでヴィハラーマアナートラ
何の病気もなく明るくいますよと
だからそこら辺でこの生きがいっていうのは
これにチャレンジしてほしい
怒らないように 心が悩まないように
本当にいい人間になることにチャレンジするんです
それが永久的に残る残るものなんです
次にススカンワタジーワーマ
ウッスケースアヌッスカ
ウッスケースマヌッスエスヴィハラーマアヌッスカ
我々ラカン人はとウッスケースアヌッスカ
ウッスカっていうのはもう直訳すると頑張っているんだという意味なんです
でも 仏教ではこれちょっといい意味の頑張っていることじゃないんです
とにかく必死になっているんだという
あれもやらなくちゃ これもやらなくちゃ
落ち着きがなくても もう朝から晩まで必死になって頑張っているという
だから否定的な意味で言ってるんです
頑張っていてありがたいという意味じゃないんです
何やってるんだ 落ち着けと
という意味で だから必死になってあれやこれやとか
朝ご飯作って それから買い物に行って
それから必死で昼ご飯作って
それから片付けて それから必死で洗濯やって
それから必死でまた晩ご飯のおかずを買って
まあ終わりがない それでまた次にお風呂
もうお風呂を入れて それからまた布団を敷いて
またもうそんなに何やと
だから人間っていうのはそうやっても一本もなく忙しいんですね
仏教はそれは笑っちゃうんですよ
もうアホじゃないかと
あまりにも下手だからそうなるんです
かなり上手に管理すると何でもうまくいくのに
その世界でウッスケースマヌス必死になっている人々の間で
ヴィハラーマアヌッサアヌッスカ
落ち着いていると 例えば仕事終わった時の喜びあるでしょ
あの喜びでいるんだよと
何か終わったら大変 なんかずっと落ち着くでしょ
あー終わったと あ よかったという
あの喜びでいつでもいるんだよと
これは悟った人々のことで
ススカンガとジーワーマ
悟った人々はすごく楽しく生活しますと
ジェーサンノーナッティキンチャナ
何もないんだから 持ち物は何もない
いわゆる煩悩は何もないという意味なんですけど
俗的にこの訳にいきましょう
持ち物は何もないんだから
そういうもんだんですよという
ピーティバッカーバイサン
我々は喜びだけで生きているんだよと
ピーチっていうのは喜び
バッカーっていうのは栄養にしている
だから仏道の人々の栄養は喜びなんです
喜びで喜びで喜びで生きている
他は何もない 財産は デーヴァアヴァシャラヤタ
この梵天のアーヴァシュラ梵天のアーヴァシュラっていうのは
このものすごい光の神という意味なんですけどね
そういう神々と同じだと
だから仏教が目指すところは
例えばこのものがあるということは
仏さんがアメリカの大統領になったんだから
それたくさんものを持ってるでしょ
だから世界の支配者にならなくちゃいけない
だからものあるということはかなりきついんですよ
それで喜びの人が何もないくても喜びだけで生きているんですね
これはまたあの喜びのことで
この競争するなよと  勝った人が何を勝つかというと
ジャヤンウェーランパソルト
敵を勝つ 買うんだよ 勝った人がたくさん敵を儲かる
敵が増えるだけ だから勝つなかれということです
ドッカンセディパラディン
負けたところで落ち込むんです
だから 勝つことも負けることもやめて落ち着きましょうと
それが楽だよという まあいろいろダンマパダありますけど
で 結論としていくつかの偈を出しますが
真面目に帰るに このある経典がありまして
死ぬまで頑張ることはこういうことに頑張ってくださいということがあるんです
こういうのは日本訳は一応山口の方で作ってはありますけど
まだ入ってないんですね
これはサリレカルニアという
ものすごい大事な経典
アショーカ王様は最後はインドの昔のね
お坊さんたちにこの経典を覚えておきなさいよと命令しているところまで大事な経典です
人々は他人に害を与える
みんな他人に害を与えることで生きている
ここで我々は他人に害を与えないようにという目的で生きている
だから他人のように生きているんじゃないんです
よく見て考えてください
世界がみんなやることやりなさいと言ってるでしょ？だってみんなやってるんだから
これやりなさいと これが恐ろしい指導なんです
仏教は逆に言うんです
みんなやらないんだからやりなさいと
だから世の中は他人に迷惑をかけること
害を与えることで 生きている
誰かを殺す 誰かを盗む
誰かの財産を奪う だからそこでだからこそ
我々は誰にも害を与えないような生き方にチャレンジする
それで パレパーナーティパーティーバリッサラ
世の中の人々は生命を殺す
戦争する 爆弾を落とす
原子爆弾も作る もう道路で歩いていても殺される可能性あるし
世の中は人を殺す 生命を殺す
それで私たちはだからこそ
誰も殺さないように生きてみる
これ 結構面白い生き方なんです
これ 人々は 与えられていないものは取る
当たり前 みんなやっています
泥棒 それでみんなやってるんだからこそ
私たちはやらないことにする
で みんな性的な邪ない行為をする
それで私たちはそこら辺ですごく落ち着いていると
みんな嘘をつく 世界は
世界は嘘をつくんだからこそ
私が嘘をつかないように生きている
えーと また道徳のリストだけ言います
世界は噂話をする で 我々は噂をしないようにする
世界は悪口を言う 我々は悪口を言わないようにする
世界は無駄話をする みんな人間は無駄話をする
だから我々は無駄話しないようにすると
それで世界があまりにも欲で
異常な欲で苦しんでいる
それで我々は異常な欲をなくす
世界は異常な怒りで苦しんでいる
我々は異常な怒りをなくす
世界は邪見で変な思考で生きている
我々は正しい思考で だからこそ正しい思考に頑張ると
世界は正しい考え方 間違っている考え方
主義 それを持っている
我々は正しい正思惟で生きている
それで八正道も入っています
世界は邪業をしているんだけど
我々は邪業はしないと
リストが 最後にミッチャーニャーニ
世界の人々の智慧というのは間違っている
そこで我々はサンマーニャーニ
正しい智慧を得ようとする
そこで世界は変なものを解脱だと思っている
天国に生まれることやらね
我々は正しい解脱にチャレンジすると
そういうことで この一生の目的なんです
それは だからいつでも嘘を言えるんだから
死ぬ瞬間まででも だから死ぬ瞬間まで心清らかな生き方しようではないかと
それでやっていると 仕事は面白くなるんですよ
友達と喋ることは面白くなるんです
だって自分は無駄話しないんだから
友達が感情的になってきついことを言っても
自分には何かチャレンジが入ってる
自分が言わないんだぞと
これがかなりチャレンジ精神で面白くなってくるんです
うまくいったよと だからこの世の中でよく言っているみんなやっているんだからしょうがないんではないかということは
僕は認めません みんなやっていることをやるのは面白くないんだよと
だから誰もやらない そういうことにチャレンジしましょうと
そのチャレンジは一生のチャレンジなんです
ですから 立派な人間になること
簡単に言えば立派な人間になることが人間の生きがいであって目的なんです
立派な人間が何をするかというと
日々幸福に生きていられる
日々充実している 日々頭がいつでも冴えている
頭が冴えているということはすごい面白いということなんです
そこで 欲 怒り 憎しみがみるみるうちに落ちしまう
その人は何にも執着しないことになるんです
だから 死ぬ時は悟って解脱して死んでるんです
だからどちらでも成功する
これはみんなこの商売繁盛ばっかり考えてる
商売繁盛と健康 2つ失うんですよ
商売繁盛でいった途端
あまり異常な欲でしょ
異常な欲があると失敗するんです
だから失敗を研究してほしい
例えば すごい美味しい好物
高価な食べ物をもらったとしますね
あまりにも高価で美味しくて
じゃあこれは後で食べましょうと
置いておいて そこで誰かが来たところで
じゃあみんなでせっかくこのごちそうを食べましょうと言ったら
もう賞味期限切れてるかもしれません
だから あまりにも欲が入っちゃうと失敗するんです
だから商売繁盛を目指す人がそれがなくなっちゃうんです
健康を目指す人には健康というものがなくなるんです
それで欲を捨てた人には何でもあり得る
要らんですけど あると
お金もいらんだけど お金はいつでもついている
健康 別にどうしたことないんだけど
自分の体は健康ですね
だから何でも成功します
そういうことで 良い人間になることが人間にある唯一な長持ちする消えない目的であるということで話を終了します
どうもありがとうございます
ありがとうございます